hi I'm Talulah Riley and I'm really
excited to be releasing my debut novel
acts of love and these are my top 5 tips
for writing something really important
is to protect your writing time fiercely
and make sure that you carve out chunks
of time where you can sit and think and
more things over and do the actual
writing and really make sure that's as
important to you as any anything else in
your diary it's really nice to have some
sort of creative inspiration for
whatever you're doing so whether that's
a particular song you listen to that you
associate with what you're writing or
the mood board or just some other
creative outlet that that mirrors the
process you're going through with your
writing and that inspires you that isn't
actually you know you always that with
your fingers on the keys I would suggest
that you not be afraid of writing and
just try and put fair in a box and
tighten up with a bone throw it away
because obviously it's a really scary
thing to do the way any creative thing
is scary but try and harness that and
use that energy as opposed to let fear
overtake you and crap lead it's really
nice to have someone that you trust a
bounce ideas off and to be your first
reader so my best friend from school
read acts of love first and was really
great about giving me constructive
criticism and you want someone that you
know will be totally honest with you but
not brutally honest so someone who will
respect the fact that what you've just
done is difficult and scary but will
give you valuable feedback
so another really important thing is to
just finish whatever you're doing I left
acts of love in a metaphorical drawer
for a year I'd written the first eight
chapters and then just didn't write the
last chapter for a year and this sort of
bothered me the whole of that year and
then when I finally took it out and
finished it there was a real sense of
achievement just in the fact that it
existed as a completed thing so even if
it doesn't feel like it's going very
well just keep going all the way through
you